next question from the point of view of
a woman who is undergoing menstration
postnatal bleeding is it prohibited or
optional for them to fast to start with
as far as the wom who are undergoing the
menstrual cycles or Postal bleeding
according to our beloved Prophet
wasallam it's mentioned in s bukari also
in say Muslim that it is forbidden for a
woman to fast who is bleeding due to
menal cycle oros n beaing so it is not
optional it is forbidden and the reason
is because when the blood flows out in a
lady in a woman she loses a lot of
blood and on top of that if she fast it
will not be good for her health so Allah
subhana wa ta'ala it is his Mercy that
he has Exempted them and made it
compulsory not to fast otherwise it may
be damaging for the health and Allah
subhana tala does not want to overburden
any of the human beings so that's the
reason they are Exempted from fasting
and even in the middle of the day if the
menstration begins they have to break
their fast even if it begins a few
minutes before Sunset they have to break
the fast but they have to compensate
later on but if they're undergoing the
menstrual period And if the period stops
just before faj even if they do not have
a bath they can start their fast but if
it ends even a few minutes after faj
they cannot fast they have to break the
fast and they have to compensate later
on